(Electronic music)
- (Jared) What’s up Wisecrack, Jared here
to talk about the show with the best fans
on the internet, Rick and Morty. Now the most
recent episode is one of our favorite of the
season so far. I mean, it’s got wet eggs:
- (Morty) I told you not to look at that egg,
it was too wet!
- (Jared) And well, uh… you know
- (Rick) Honestly I’m proud of us for not…
- (Jared) But what we found most interesting
about this episode is the basic question it
poses: how much should nature define us?
Welcome to this Wisecrack Quicktake on Rick
and Morty Season 4 Episode 7: Promorteus
And duh… spoilers ahead.
So the basic premise of Promorteus is this:
there’s a parasitic, face-hugging alien
species that exerts total control of their
host and, has a life span of about 30 minutes.
After depositing an egg, said host explodes,
killing itself and the proud parasite mommy
- (Alien) Suck on face, sh** an egg, and die!
- (Jared) But Summer, using a fool-proof oral
defense mechanism, escapes enslavement and
convinces the parasites to forego their reproductive
urges to live a longer, more fulfilling life.
As a result, the parasites are able to quickly
build a sprawling society with media, matching
skyscrapers, and pearl harbors. And then of
course, Rick blows it all up - minus the twin
skyscrapers, of course.
- (Morty) Totally would’ve been cheap
- (Rick) Yeah real low hanging fruit, we’re
better than that.
- (Jared) Also Jerry has bees.
I think one of the most interesting elements
of this episode lies in this small gag: Parasite
Rick Glorzo-tube rants against the progressive
agenda of living longer. Now, at first, this
seems like a a quick jab at people like Alex
Jones
- (Parasite Rick) Did I least sell out and
sell vitamins or something?
- (Jared) But the basic concept is mirrored
everywhere in the episode. That is: if something
is natural, does that make it right?
Face-hugger Rick’s argument for the murder/suicide
of host and parasite is based on quote unquote
science
- (Parasite Rick) Here's a scientific fact
I'm not “allowed to say" - our hosts are
biologically designed to incubate your eggs...
if that triggers you, f*** off!
- (Jared) Of course, this is not actually
science, it’s the mention of science in
a logical fallacy: the appeal to nature fallacy.
That is, the idea that if something is natural,
it is inherently good, desirable, or even
inevitable. This kind of fallacy pops up everywhere.
In the debate about same-sex marriage, many
people would argue that homosexuality was
unnatural, and therefore immoral. Then again,
getting mauled by a tiger IS perfectly natural,
but that doesn’t mean it’s good. This
the appeal to nature fallacy in action. Others
would point to the fact, correctly, that homosexuality
is natural among many of our closest animal
relatives - which again, is still a logical
fallacy, since dictating where you can or
can’t stick your genitals based on what
does or doesn’t happen in nature is a logical
fallacy.
This fallacy also pops up often around the
idea that “might is right,” the idea that
people are justified to rule by strength alone.
That claim usually gets backed up by citing
Darwinism, whatever primates do or don’t
do in the wild, or our evolutionary history
of humans being dicks. Pretty much, every
time you hear about monkeys, primates, or
our cave-men ancestors, you should stop listening
to that person. Except that’s a fallacy
fallacy, dismissing a conclusion outright
because its logic was flawed - ****. Anyway.
Everyone shut up about monkeys already.
Parasite Rick’s argument is exactly this
kind of appeal to nature. , He says “we
should deposit our eggs because the hosts
can biologically sustain them”. He also
has a poster on his wall that displays a kind
of might-is-right logic, reading that “Glorzo’s
are supreme,” and hosts are subservient,
which echoes plenty of bad appeals to nature
found in places like social darwinism. The
progress of Summer on the other hand, is about
moving past biology determining one’s future
- (Parasite Morty) Let’s just get the hell
out of here and be whatever the fuck we want,
that’s evolution, that’s progress!
- (Jared) But there’s also a more subtle
critique going on here. Important to this
episode, and life, is that people, when appealing
to nature, often set up an arbitrary divide
between good nature and bad nature.
- (Parasite Rick) F*** since we were in eggs?
Oh yeah yeah yeah, what, now you respect like
the biological institutions now? F*** you!
- (Jared) People arguing that same-sex marriage
is bad because it’s unnatural usually have
no problem watching YouTube for 8-hours a
day, getting blood transfusions, or being
temperature regulated by the liquid remains
of dinosaurs.
Similarly, Parasite Rick has no problem enjoying
the unnatural spoils of civilization or non-reproductive,
arguably incestual, face-sucking while railing
against the repression of biological processes
- (Parasite Morty) How come you haven’t
laid an egg inside this old man yet?
- (Parasite Rick) Because I do what I want!
- (Jared) Similarly, one could “respect
nature” while “despising” parts of it
that seem icky or just dangerous. Like snakes
which have historically been labeled in some
cultures as evil incarnate.
- (Morty) What is that?
- (Tick) Obviously it’s a space snake.
- (Morty) There’s snakes in space?
- (Jared) And of course, there’s parasites,
which, to my knowledge, don’t really have
too many positive representations in the media
. It’s pretty much a default to think of
them as a mindless
- (Rick) They're face-hugging parasites I
don't think their society is going to be that
difficult to navigate
- (Jared) And evil
- (Morty) I’m sorry we thought you were
evil!
- (Alien) Why would you think that? We had
a giant tower blared Glorzo is peace!
- (Morty) I know, I should, should, should
we help?
- (Jared) But here’s where the episode gets
really interesting, because this looking down
on our face-huggers is, in a weird way, a
mirror image of Parasite Rick. Normal Rick
views parasites as lowly, a lesser form of
life. As Rick and Morty commit mass murder
they note how good is feels to cause mayhem
without guilt.
- (Rick) Damn feels kind of good when there’s
no guilt
- (Morty) Yeah it’s just like in Star Wars
- (Rick) Yeah just like in Star Wars
- (Jared) Comparing it to popping bubble wrap
- not destroying an advanced civilization.
- (Rick) Oh my god this is so much fun!
- (Morty) I don’t want to stop!
- (Rick) Yeah it’s like popping bubblewrap!
- (Jared) But this idea is constantly undercut
as the show likens Rick and Morty’s violence
to American tragedies
- (Beth) So you did a 9/11?
- (Morty) Almost did a 9/11, we, we went with
a Pearl Harbor. We’re pretty classy.
- (Beth) Why were either of those two an option?
- (Jared) Morty even comments:
- (Morty) Should have been a better species!
- (Jared) echoing might-is-right justification
for destroying their world before becoming
horrified by his actions.
- (Morty) Sorry. I’m sorry!
- (Jared) It’s not all that different than
Parasite Rick’s justification for enslaving
host species - humans killing parasites is
just some old-fashioned natural pest control,
even if by some unnatural means.
There’s also just a really interesting question
here that I love. There’s a basic hypothetical:
Is it fair to call a species evil for just
reproducing as their nature dictates? What
would happen if we encountered an intelligent
alien that could only survive by living parasitically
off another sentient alien? Is there even
a line in the sand we can draw, as a species
that lives off of eating other species? Just
some FOOD for thought.